yeah hello and welcome to this video so
I have a bit late I just hit the wrong
button there and yeah therefore we are
in the game already for a couple of
moves playing mr. top-hat
Jones here on D chest a player that I
have lost against perform not yet I'm
not yet on the score but I remember that
game there was very silly loss where I
was in good shape and then yeah
basically killed myself and okay let's
see what happens here it's a Petrov
where white has gone for a little bit of
an unusual way of playing him did not
prevent he was Bishop d3 did not prevent
Bishop g4 sorry Bishop g4 and now he's
gone for that King side expansion okay I
think I'm not going to castle very
quickly yeah I wanted to wait for that
and then maybe take I think I'm going to
caption now he's gained some space on
the Kings side I wonder if I should if I
should cancel on Kings side here or not
it's not entirely entirely clear to me
oh and that's an interesting move I was
thinking about it and I wasn't really
sure what to make of it if this is a
good choice or not okay I will go c5 for
this benoni structure
I think this at least should discourage
Gavin he has to cancel off where is he
going to get yeah where is he going to
put the king
Kim I cannot keep the king on the 8th so
I have to cancel
yeah this is an interesting interesting
move and I wasn't sure what to make of
it if I go here and I will I'm at least
there and it stops it stops the age porn
at least yeah and no yeah
what to do do it go I wondered if b5 is
a move just like toss a pawn just for
the tempo mainly this one I would like
to get b5 in without playing a 6 that
would be nice
okay yeah that night is about positioned
maybe he just wants to go 93 down yeah
it's very like him that's very likely
okay
the tech is going to be quick if the
tech is going to be quite quick ok
anyhow I have to push myself on the
queenside
yeah that was the drawback of Knight h5
but okay it still takes a moment until
he's opening up files c4 is giving away
the d4 square but I still probably have
to do that simply to get to get going
okay 95 you might take it home okay so
maybe you need to be six
trying for night a for maybe yeah six d6
is obviously a huge hole but not much
that I could do about it and the main
issue with this move is actually that I
cannot go to B form once this hits quite
quite awful
okay I'm not going to survive that
and that was a bit of a disaster I'm not
even totally sure what went wrong to be
honor
I don't know I mean I'm not saying I
play great or anything I'm just saying
I'm not totally sure what the the point
was where it was impossible to save it
it's age seven me okay it was it was
lost anyway hmm that was interesting it
was interesting yeah one thing that I'm
never totally certain about is if I
should play d5 or not they should go d5
or not maybe Knight d7 is also the same
issue I mean the thing is by not playing
d5 I retain the option of maybe getting
in Knight to d5 that can be very
interesting actually if you're gonna be
fine and I put a knight on to d5 it's
going to be a very strong piece this is
why I'm trying to delay d5 quite often
in such a situation however here after
d5 it was a bit of a problem maybe I
shouldn't go c5 I don't know in okay
let's look at this the engine is already
hating my position really one point
something is really bad actually with
short castles hmm okay
but Long's probably okay swell for him
now so on g5 and now we went age form
and looks low to me but it's probably
just not great this may be the plan
users to slow I don't know 94 I went be
593 yeah I mean okay c4 is essentially
what killed me
yeah but the position already is is
probably bad um I'm just too slow now
I'm just too stone and this is not good
them those pieces are not good so what
is the issue
what am I doing wrong here first of all
playing this move is considered to be
inaccurate yeah you should go h3 first
so I feel I should be fine that this is
a funny evaluation ok the engine is not
really on any considerable depth but
it's pretty clear that the position is
no plus one for white I mean that that
simply cannot cannot be the case but ok
so Age 3 and when g4 and just fish
should be three so probably around here
is where I should try to improve so c6
I'm fairly certain about that this
should be okay and Queen e2 which okay
yeah one thing that comes to mind is
definitely this as well not just d5 but
also night a6 I think this this is
making a lot of sense the night is quite
okay here and I still have this idea to
put the piece onto d5 I mean one thing
that you have to also keep in mind is
that if he cancels long which is still
probably unlikely to happen even though
the engine doesn't approve but human the
human still I could consider I am not
sure if it's a good idea but I could
consider two to castlelong myself it's
kind of unnecessary this is actually
looking very logical I don't know where
the queen is going I can't and just
really do that or maybe the other night
it's probably more logical this this for
example looks completely reasonable for
black yeah well one point is that here
without the double pawn we had the
situation we had to take on g3 the the
tech is going to be a lot less of
threatening the F file is not open land
as long you know 2g bonds yeah yeah I'm
quite quite okay with with my position
the night here is really a fine piece
this is a lot better than in the game of
the night on d7 sitting passively and I
have this idea here now yeah I think
this this is probably what I have to do
I I'm not really that experience in
those positions generally and it seems
that I probably have to make sure that
this move was not happening it happened
to me before in games and this is a
simple way of doing it and 96
not any more sophisticated way of doing
it probably this is what I have to do in
the opening yeah thanks a lot for
watching